[Music]
not often does an elite professional
athlete
become a police officer it takes a
special kind of strong to leave one
frightening arena and enter another one
but when it works it's a special kind of
rewarding
he's 5-5 and could easily kick your
instead ulysses gomez wears the badge
with integrity
and reflects on the lessons from the
streets he patrols
as an adult we could talk ourselves into
a fight we could talked ourselves out of
a fight
for over a decade yuley talked himself
into a fighting career
the el dorado high school grad won his
way up the professional
mma ranks and made his way to the top of
the sport
ufc in 2013. my point probably was i got
i got two roll titles one at 125 and
135. i mean i learned something from
every fight he also learned the mma life
has an expiration date when the bell
rang on one career
another came calling on the tragic night
of october first i wish i was there
and it's not because i don't think that
i could have changed anything to happen
but i would like to be there to help
people so that's
the main reason why i'm here this
grappler grabbed a hold of a new passion
and wouldn't let go in 2018 officer
ulysses gomez was sworn into the las
vegas metropolitan police department
having other officers who have that
level of ability and level that talent
that they've gained over years of
training
it's a great asset for not just a
training unit but the department in
general
officer gomez is a defensive tactics
instructor now but his resume
resonates with his new teammates i'm
going to teach a guy who's been policing
for 15
20 years that what he's been doing
there's a better way to do it and he's
going to be like
what do you know you've been out for
three years so that's why i explained my
background being great
is the gomez game yulie's brother
hercules
played in the world cup as one of the
greatest soccer players in u.s history
elite technique is in the blood
sometimes the police officers
have this us versus them mentality
towards them
but he connects on the ground level on a
common level with with people
so it's pretty cool to see how he's kind
of
intertwined all these different aspects
of his life unlike the octagon the
street's ulysses police's don't play by
the rules
but he's hungry to fight for them anyway
as
as much as i wanted 5 feet oc i'm more
proud to wear this uniform
protect and serve right